astros were banging away against the
oakland a's at dodger stadium they've
got a tough left-hander on the mound ron
darling a former cy young award winner a
couple of seasons ago and blake snell
yeah as tough as they get in his first
four career games and the postseason two
starts two relief appearances is era
under one but against the yankees in
game one he gave up three home runs and
four runs in five minutes jose altuve
with one away the 2-1
and altuve lifts this one in the air
pretty deep to left it sends back marco
at the wall looking up see you later
jose altuve goes deep and the astros go
up one to nothing
and he gives the astros the early lead
tonight on a 2-1 count jose altuve
sends one into the seats in left field
it's post season now four for five with
three home runs against left-handed
pitching well
hobart in
game four the clinching game and now
he's back with a home run and his first
at-bat and he's talking about a shot to
set his team at ease to get started
tucker dude next three and one is right
down the middle and correa breaks his
back and rolls out to end the inning he
was the breakout star in the wild card
series and then on into the division
series hitless in his last two games and
he's still hitting 444 for the
postseason the one-two
ugly swing and an elevated fastball the
rose arena swinging a fly swatter at
that and that's back-to-back strikeouts
for valdez to away rezarena is going to
go to somebody in the analytics
department and say i thought you said he
was going to throw a curve with two
strikes
because that's where he's swung the bat
one two pitch
and then on his hands foul territory
long run renfro makes the play
he knows this outfield as well as anyone
after his years with the san diego
padres
traded to the rays
and finally able to get a start here in
the san diego portion of this postseason
it's almost seems sometimes that it's a
walk through the park with valdez he'll
toss that baseball in the air he'll have
a smile on his face shouldn't be this
easy but it's been that easy for fromber
and a swing at a miss down he goes
valdez with a strikeout as he gets
renfro that's his fourth strikeout all
of his outs are cased thus far
two seams out of the fingers of valdez
and he gets to swing and miss from
renfrow
here's willy adams
one and one to adamus
on the ground
correa to second out there altuve's turn
and it's picked and it's a double play
julie guriel
the astros with the first two on here in
the fourth inning nobody out for kyle
tucker tucker a dead pull hitter and he
sends one a line of right to adamus who
steps on the bag for a double play
[Applause]
headed right into that shift adamus was
there that ball had some knuckle ball
action off the bat it had a little
wobble on its way out oh as close as you
can get but certainly the foot on the
back first blake snell knows that's a
big out and everybody's safe the astros
have them loaded up in this fourth
inning correa leads at third uriel at
second d is at first the pitch to
maldonado here's a swing and a fly ball
to right field but it should be playable
for renfro he's there to make the catch
and that will retire the side the astros
did everything but score a run in that
fourth inning they leave him loaded
here's randy rosarena he struck out his
first time the one-two pitch lifted in
the air to center field back out of the
springer still going back to the wall
it's gone
randy rosarino runs into one and he's
tied this game at one here in the fourth
inning with his fourth home run this
postseason it's one to one
randy a rosarito the fastball killer
just got one and did not miss
and his magical post season continues
this guy continues to bring the thunder
this postseason with some huge home runs
they have a runner in scoring position
for keermeyer adama's ready to run at
second one away in the inning
and back oh my goodness what a play that
was
oh okay
from valdez with some nifty glove work
right there for the second out of the
inning adamus advances to third base but
go ahead and mark that one down well
he's got a smile too
two outs in the inning here is zunino
first ball swinging and it's through the
shift for a base hit adamus will score
and the rays have taken a two to one
lead mike zunino ambushing the first
pitch it's an rbi single
and tampa bay is on top here in this
fifth inning see what he has in mind one
and two one man out sixth inning and uh
swaying adam is renfro strikes out
he's got him again third time he struck
out renfo and that's number eight
for valdez
has him in a hole here big pitch coming
two on two outs and the o2 is on the
ground correa
will go across the diamond and it's in
time to get the speedy margot and that
will retire the side diego castillo
on the mound a hot situation brewing
here bases loaded eighth inning 2-1
tampa bay lead i'm saying this first
pitch to gurio is grounded back up
toward the middle could it be two lao
has it the second out throw the first
one pitch a double play and they get out
of it it goes four to three and diego
castillo pulls a houdini act he gets out
of that mess and the astros
it's an out the second out of the inning
but the tying run now at second
here we go the one ball two strike pitch
from castillo swinging a miss he struck
him out the ball game is over the rays
have defeated the astros and lead the
american league championship series one
game to nothing